now to the suspected Chinese spy balloon
that raised tensions between the U.S and
China and Air Force fighter jets shot
down the balloon off the South Carolina
coast on Saturday and a recovery
operation is underway this morning China
said the U.S hyped up the incident on
purpose the U.S says the balloon flight
was a clear violation of international
law Nancy Cordis is at the White House
this morning where officials are
defending their response Nancy good
morning good morning David yeah the
White House has been strenuously arguing
all weekend that waiting to shoot this
balloon down was the safest thing for
people on the ground and enabled them to
gather valuable intelligence overnight
though the Chinese accused the U.S of an
indiscriminate use of force even as some
of the president's critics argue he
wasn't forceful enough
the Chinese balloon may be down now but
the political fight over it rages on I
think this entire episode uh telegraphed
weakness to she and the Chinese
government in Washington Sunday
Republicans argued that the balloon the
size of three school buses should have
been taken out over the Pacific before
it even entered U.S airspace in Alaska
the president was paralyzed for an
entire week by a balloon the balloon's
seven-day cross-country Journey took it
over Idaho Montana Missouri and
eventually to the South Carolina coast
they shot it we're an F-22 fired a
single air-to-air missile and sent the
equipment hurtling into the Atlantic
Ocean I told them to shoot it down oh
Wednesday on Wednesday but the
recommendation they said to me let's
wait till the safest place to do it
senior Administration officials argued
that closely observing the balloon in
Flight Before shooting it down allowed
them to better understand the Chinese
program and further confirmed its
mission was surveillance we sent a clear
message to China that this is not
acceptable
we protected civilians
we gained more intelligence while
protecting our own sensitive information
White House officials say similar
Chinese spyballoons entered U.S airspace
at least three times during the Trump
years though this information they say
was discovered after the prior
Administration left on Friday yet
another Chinese balloon was spotted over
Latin America all this comes just as the
U.S was trying to dial down tensions
with China Chinese are now claiming the
U.S overreacted even as Secretary of
State Anthony blinken called off a
diplomatic trip to China at the last
minute it's not a coincidence that this
happens leading up to the State of the
Union Address leading up to blinken's
visit to China
President Biden's State of the Union
Address is taking place tomorrow night
and the administration is considering
taking further action against China over
all of this the full Senate is expected
to get a clear classified briefing this
week about China's spying capabilities
because clearly Gail there's a lot more
to be learned
yeah a lot of questions here Nancy thank
you so much